voi non siete pronti alla vita da tutti
ragazzi e per i leader sono video sono
fa vj vorrei parlarvi pronto leggere
queste cose molto importanti sono una
grave una grande epidemia di gatti ma
certo giocando gatti hanno invaso il
mondo hanno invaso anche internet pegolo
da da una vita a finire che possono
andare avanti perché va bene così non
volevo non voglio sapere altro allo
ragazzi della schermata di gioco
possiamo innanzitutto capire la
malvagità di questi felini
non ho capito bene di che razza di cosa
si tratta però basta whatsapp è ragazzi
vi spiego se noi andiamo su start in
teoria ci dovrebbe far combattere la
madonna a ma possiamo dare possiamo
parlare in giro con me nella mappa
dell'europa
i gatti hanno invaso tutta europa
compresa napoli ce ne sono andati a
napoli i gatti a napoli dobbiamo
difendere napoli adesso io vi spiego dic
in che cosa consiste questo gioco
validata noi abbiamo la nostra torre è
che questa cui vive e poi c'è la torre
di gatti che sarebbe la torre della
città per che cazzo c'è la torre di pisa
a napoli va bene crea i gatti forti
allora io un'armata di gatti questo che
cosa mica sto vedendo se c'è una lavata
di gatti in poco i cani un po un po
maurizio merluzzo che picchiano le le
persone anzi no le i conigli in quanti
canne si sono fatti quando hanno
problemi
vabbé non fa niente la cosa fighissima
di questo gioco e che in teoria per
avanzare di livello e creare sempre
difese di gatti in questo caso posso
creare il gioco dell'anno la torre di
pisa sta sfornando scoiattoli e
rinoceronti e conigli rossi se non vale
tutto il gioco solo questo non lo so ho
un miliardo di aromatico questo che si
ubriaca ma che cazzo degli ato è il
problema grosso è che io non essendo
come esperto visto gioco ma sì che lo
vinco porca erano lo spam agli elefanti
e picchi altre maledetti vi stanno
picchiando la torre che non è un segno
però va bene dopo aver spinto i maya è
così
ciò pochissima vita la fase sia poco
forse già forme nate maledetti del sumo
878 rimasto pochissimo lega perché
questo ci ha un chiodo per lo stomaco
spiegami come può essermi utile ragazzi
ce la sto facendo non so come mai la mia
armata ha preso il sopravvento a napoli
conquistiamo a napoli ho sudato per la
tuta prima metà di gioco questi fino a
quasi morire mi anima solamente 876
pochissimo adesso atac ha dato la di
pisa attaccate attaccate da carne la
torre di pisa
tu sarai un po bischero mena la torre
mirana donne poiché sono riuscita vi non
so come perché stavo giocando lì blu
pensavo di perdere tutta la vita invece
no vinto bene quindi ragazzi questa più
o meno per farvi capire come esso gioco
di difendere la tua base attaccare di
buttare giù quella degli altri creando
gatti grossi forti aiuta riesce tua non
so parlare sei sicuro di voler usare il
cibo per gatti si
ma gang che se sono scatolette che si
sono aperte superaro ho trovato il gatto
volte va bene spero sia cosa sta minkia
in questo piatto deforme mercat
va bene il gatto primitivo jurassic cat
viking che era bellissimo film che il
gatto che kiev ha carichi a molla va
bene bigatto david bowie
credo sia la rocker che ha criticato
nerd o gesù che ho fatto bello ha mai
messo l'inter posso fare l'upgrade tipo
di quelli muscolosi diciamo l'upgrade al
macho cat o potremmo potenziato il gatto
colloquio in cui maurizio merluzzo dei
gatti come ci sono arrivati alla o ai
gatti sulla luna kiss tramin chi è
questo ci stanno già attaccando ho
capito dammi un attimo chi sono questi
picchiate picchiate maledetti che prima
abbiamo vinto per miracolo adesso non ci
possiamo più
c'è un tizio grosso che degusta il vino
lipica fatto frigo ti vai così picchiate
maledetti picchiate dovrei riuscire
arrivare a 4425 che c'è quello che
potenziato al massimo prima secondo con
un gatto con un chiodo nel nel petto
come può essere forte c'è un chiodo nel
tetto come come fa a combattere spiega
non voglio saperlo ora che va bene così
i ragazzi stanno arrivando alla torre
regala veloci quanto tempo porca di una
line a è mai così mica avevo caffè
quantum e quante limitata bello questo
gioco all'improvviso mi chiara che mi
sono salvato di nuno e l'ultimo club
acton golosa devo concentrarmi zitto mi
sono salvato di nuova l'ultima evocando
una roba a caso perché mi stanno
attaccando la base non so come ho fatto
c'è culo il mio massimo
bye bye a fire non ho idea di quanto
danno faccia sta roba che ho evocato ma
è sexy eva penosi e la madonna si
propagano maledizione poi danno che
questi ci picchiano dai ziato potenziato
al ventimiglia disseccare tutti con un
colpo veloce evoca anche l'ultimo gol a
pato mia
mai ce li ho tutti che hai mangiato
delle scatolette belle pesanti far
diventare così zio continua evoca
continua evocare gli ai gatti che ho
dati come se potessero servire qualcosa
ma mi sa che non servono una beata
minchia figlia ragazzi la presa della
bastiglia e sta era più semplice ma
comunque quali la loro torre embrace the
wild west di fate fuori il satana che
sta degustando del vino chianti da
un'ora e mezza per cortesia questo
volevo porterà questo volevo lanciamo
più le difese vai così in chi crede
anche stavolta visto un salvatore
l'ultimo impossibile a meno che non esca
ogni un altro ma non credo che forse
eccolo lì eccolo lì il mio amico ci ho
messo una vita per quanto è durata st
partite un anno e mezzo
qualcosa mi dice che ho vinto però non
ne sono completamente sicuro potrei
potrei non vincere quanto li sto facendo
il collega by così ho evocato anche la
mia prof di matematica cosa si che fa
danni
ho sudato come una lepre morta è stata
un mezzo è impossibile non ce l'ho fatta
l'importante quello ha suonato anche
un'altra figlia ho spronato detto le fa
chi è gesù roulant ansia comunque io non
volevo fare un altra roba prima di
entrare volevo mettere a posto
l'equipaggiamento per il re tu vuoi
cambiare le cose ci lasciamo stare la
[ __ ] che adesso non cambierò
assolutamente sexy wags cat
perché non l'ho messo prima è che
avremmo vinto sicuro fatemi riprovare
sono curiosissimo solo per vedere come
sono non è che mi frega niente non è
solo capire con me non so se la vivono
mi basta solo vedere se riesco a usare
quelli nuovi commesso comunque sia sta
roba dei gatti che conquistano la vita è
colpa di sasha e di sapri perché se
continuano ad adottare i gatti porca
vacca è normale che conquisteranno il
mondo per cederlo per acquistare un
[ __ ] unica nota partita ho fatto solo
per vedere come sono le gambe di gatti
solo per quello per me possiamo
includere qui ragazzi e abbiamo così in
questo è stata più semplice ragazzi
quello di prima era fortissimo perché ce
l'ha fatta anche di gustav al chianti
cos'è quanto non fa paura questo corso
che comunque raga disintegrato leo ai
due gatti fa mi preparo che lesività
proprio come se fosse provato totti in a
pec
cos'altro gatto grazie ai ragazzi questa
è la batte il cash game che gli lascia
anche in descrizione io direi che
possono più le più episodi avete
apprezzato le mie capacità di
conquistatore spero che visto che sia
piaciuto cosi al momento non mi piace
anche nel giorno del comune di detenere
tiziano qualcuno mi venga a spiegare
perché a napoli ci stava la torre di
pisa e noi ci vediamo a un prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]